what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 27th
of the [__] september
from the heart of new jersey the joint
is brought to you by
draftkings listen
three weeks of football are in the books
time to review the tapes get ready with
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the nfl listen
there's some great games coming up this
weekend draftkings has an offer that's
[__] crazy you ready they're giving
all new customers 150 dollars instantly
what are you joey what are you talking
about 150
just bet one dollar on any [__]
football game and it starts tonight you
heard me [__] fat so head to draft
king sportsbook app today right now
there's a great game on tonight monday
night i think it's uh washington
whatever but i'll [__] double check
yeah no it's the eagles
against the dallas [__] cowboys i
think so head over to draftkings
sportsbook app today better dollar and
get 150
free
that's what you're doing sportsbook is
not yet available in your state
draftkings has huge prizes for grabs all
season long
on the fantasy app however you play
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at a million dollars in total
prizes in their first deposit download
the draftking sportsbook app today use
promo code joey j-o-e-y get 150 and free
bets when you place a dollar bet on any
football game that's promo code joey
this week's draftking sports sportsbook
app the official sports betting partner
of the nfl new jersey indiana
pennsylvania colorado west virginia new
customers only minimum five hour deposit
and a one dollar wager required that's
it six dollars
six dollars to get your [__] party
started see draftkings.com
for details now if you got a gaming
problem call 1-800 gambler if you're in
indiana
call
1-800-9 with it
but if everything is beautiful
download the draftking sportsbook app
today
or the fantasy app and let's win some
[__] guitars remember they got a
casino that's second to none blackjack
poker
[__]
download the draftking sportsbook app
use promo code joey and let's win some
[__] guitars it starts tonight with
monday night football the joint is also
brought to you by bowl and branch
bowling branch knows it takes more than
a good mattress to get a good night's
sleep you gotta have nice and
comfortable sheets
bowling branch are ultra [__] soft
plus they're 100 organic and sustainably
produced let me tell you something my
wife has sheets these are the best
[__] sheets i've ever gotten in my
life
they got sheets of soft and smooth and
comfortable i got my bed looking sharp
with the new natural colored sheets
check out the signature hem sheets also
they're the best sellers for a good
reason they get softer after every wash
you understand me
get ready for this bowling branch has a
guarantee enjoy any product for 30 days
to experience the best sheets you've
ever felt
choose bowling branch you can try them
worry free for 30 nights with free
shipping and returns so try them you got
nothing to [__] lose plus
my listeners get an exclusive 15 off
your first set of sheets that's 15 off
30 days money back
guarantee if you don't like them use
promo code joey at
bowlandbranch.com again
that's
bowlingbranch.com b-o-l-l
and branch b-r-a-n-c-h
dot com
use promo code joey now if there's
nothing else let's get this party
started
the joint is coming at you monday
september 27th post smokers
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 27th we did it
the month is almost [__] over i love
it it's [__] monday morning
had a great week last week i don't know
if you guys have noticed
this [__] month
has gone
just [__] quicker than [__] i still
remember being the first i remember
being the fifth
and every day i looked at the dates and
said what the [__] is going on
now it's the 27th
[__] fall is here the [__] leaves
have fallen it's beautiful out we're in
[__] jerk let me tell you something
there's something about the east coast
that i got to tell you guys a lot of you
guys notice
a lot of you guys don't
there's nothing better in life for me
i've always known this the summers are
[__] humid they suck dick i [__]
hate humidity
but there's nothing
like an east coast fall
and an east coast spring
from now from like september one let me
put to this way
[__] neutral and ask anybody [__]
new jersey in the summers are a
nightmare because every weekend are
ruined by [__] rain or cloudiness
ask mike god is my witness since
since september 1st
the weekends have been [__] gorgeous
when i tell you gorgeous i mean 77
degrees not a cloud in the [__] sky
not even a plane not a helicopter
nothing [__] sun out no humidity
that's what the weekends have been it's
been the weirdest [__] summer here
the summer was dick i mean i enjoyed
myself i went to the pool i jumped up
and down you know i worked out i [__]
went to pittsburgh it was a great summer
i mean i stuck to my [__] guns
but the weather was [__] like just
shitty
september has been
to the point where you don't want to be
inside
like you're like [__] this i'm going on
the mornings are cool
once the sun goes down and [__] holy
[__] we had a practice friday night the
girls had softball practice
it was beautiful sat a friday afternoon
but let me tell you something once that
sun
hides behind the [__] trees you're
like what the [__]
you got to bring a sweatshirt another
sweatshirt and a sweatshirt for the
sweatshirt but it was a fun [__]
weekend uh
we went to uh we had practice friday
night
two games on [__] saturday yeah they
lost both of them you know the coach
it's it's an all-star weekend it's an
all-star traveling team so we had to go
to [__] trenton
and uh the girls were 10 and 11. i
remember mercy being
at first base
and it was like a [__] standing next
to me like that's how big the girl was
compared to mercy but they did great
they did the best they could you know
the coach did it on purpose because he
wanted them to
you know play up a little bit like just
to get when you play it's like it's like
running with a vest on you know and then
you take the vest off and you're [__]
you know like uh you know you're flying
through the [__] alley bruce lee but
when you have the vest on it puts weight
on you these girls were bigger they were
throwing harder but mercy did great i
was very proud of her she caught a
couple pop-ups
she made a double [__] play a play at
first and she threw it home and the girl
got it wrong
you know what man listen i'm not a a
pistol pete maravich father i'm not at
home whipping her watching a basement
i'm not listen
in that dugout i just want to hear a
giggle
if i could hear a giggle on the field in
the dugout with her friends whether
they're losing or winning i don't give a
[__]
she's doing so much [__] better than
what she was doing in la
so much
[__] today i had her out early uh yes
sunday day before we went to church i
had her out early
playing with the [__] neighbors let
me tell you something guys she has these
two little neighbor buddies i mean she's
got all these little girlfriends and
kids from school and
the parents we roll with but the
neighbor kids and her
all she needs i could tell let me tell
you something she's going to end up
dating that kid from across the street i
can just tell i know my daughter
i know my daughter her and her and him
she's uh he's 10 mercy's eight
but they get along perfectly they're
both geeks
they're into that
you know [__] coding and all that
stuff
when they get on the computer together
the other day i went to the practice i
went to the football practice just some
night nights during the week i meet the
other parents their sons have games and
i go to their football practice i watch
i talk we [__] we get out we get
some air we look at the bats you know
i'm saying there's [__] bats over
there
so mercy was there with
frankie and they said can we go over to
the park i go yeah now
the park is far away i can't really see
him
there's nothing going on at that park
you know but after 15 20 minutes i walk
over i gotta take a pee anyway and i
check on them there's a thousand kids at
the park at [__] 6 30. it's amazing
it's like jersey when i was growing up
here
when i walk over there to see what's
going on like there's a bunch of kids
and i'm like i can't recognize mercy and
often i look at one of the tables
and i see mercy
and little frankie sitting there
[__] having a great time you know
like just giggling and looking at the
computer and i'm like
these [__] kids you know they're just
uh
dead and then he has a little sister
she's a year younger than mercy maybe
two years younger than mercy and they
get along great so
everything i have everything i need is
right in front of the [__] house
uh went to the san genero feast and
manalapan holy [__]
holy [__]
the line for the [__] zeppelies was
from here to philadelphia i was like i'm
not getting on that
but
i did get myself a little [__]
sausage sandwich a hot
sausage and peppers
holy [__] it was [__] good this
wasn't a truck
this was a stand with some old catholics
working on this [__]
catholics know how to make sausage of
[__] peppers
it was tremendous i hadn't been to a
[__] san general feast since
1984 over in little italy the san genero
feast is going on little italy but
i'm not going over there no i'm not
[__] going over there i have a little
feast over here they had zepplies they
had lobster rolls they had italian ice
they had
five shrimp for a dollar
five nice like shrimp cocktails dollars
shrimp cocktails i have like two of them
i'm like give me give me ten [__]
five shrimps for a dollar
i talked to a few people they had a
little petting zoo
mercy had a great time with the [__]
petting zoo
and that was it man i went to
acupuncture last week i went to [__]
jiu jitsu last week and i got to be
honest with you
it was
like i told the [__] dude i go you
know sean is a great coach
great kid i mean i have hit the jackpot
with this kid
all we're going to do is we're going to
do some basics for a few weeks
everything from the close guard
and then i'm actually gonna join the
school i'm not gonna [__] around i need
to meet people
i need to get some camaraderie in my
life i need to [__] get out there and
do more things
mike and i were talking about the other
day there's no open mics
for mike i mean [__] has not really
opened up to the fullest
in our world a lot of these places where
mike used to go they're not opening you
know but still
i got to change my life around it's
starting to change i've done a
i've done a great job the last 90 days i
really got to be honest with you guys
i've really focused down on a lot of
things i'm healthier
the anxiety has dropped uh [__] 50
percent
i'm probably running at 85 percent right
now and uh
it feels great i'm getting great sleep
my workouts are great you know
just me going to jiu jitsu i told sean
on the way out the other day oh this
wasn't about jiu jitsu
this was about me getting healthier
you know i'm 58 obviously i'm a [__]
old man i'm not planning on going to the
pan americans
or [__] uh you know ac dc whatever
the [__] tournament is
all i want to do is just be healthy and
my mind to be healthy and if it means
going and sweating on some people and
some people sweating on me and [__] it's
great that's all it is i'm not planning
on being a it's like the guitar i just
want to play it as therapy
you know that's it i'm playing my little
smoke on the water it sounds like
[__] uh
i don't know it sounds like [__]
apocalypse now on the water you know but
i tried my [__] best you know
the ufc was great last night uh
my heart goes out to brian ortega he
fought a [__]
tremendous fight um you know he never
stopped and that's what you want to see
from those fights
the diaz lawler fight we all knew what
the result was gonna be of that i was
gonna bet it but there was there was no
money in the fight i i bet uh
on
robbie lawler to knock him out in the
[__] uh i put the second round
instead of the third i would have won 20
250 bucks on a 25 bet so
that was the only thing i fought on the
on the
that's the only bet i made on the
[__] card
i thought i would take it would give i
thought he was going to surprise him but
i was wrong
i finally got beat up at the ufc
ortega took a [__] beat but he kept
pushing
diaz listen man the diaz is i don't
think they want to fight they want to
they want to fight like i want to do
comedy you know what i'm saying like
it's always in the back burner but you
really don't want to do it and when you
do it it's a force do you see what i'm
trying to say to you you can't fake the
funk guys you can never fake the funk if
you don't want to do something move the
[__] on don't do it because of money do
it because you really want to be in that
it's so weird how i met so many people
the last 10 years
of my comedy career more than the
beginning
that were just in this for the [__]
doe like they didn't love it
they didn't like sitting there
and [__] you know
writing they just it was whatever made
them dull they would tell you
we think i could make more dough doing
this doing that what about liking it
how about liking it that's that [__]
that's a definite
[__] path to unhappiness is doing
something you don't like and you're
hearing it from me because i've always
loved comedy i've adored comedy but for
the last four years after 2016
i was struggling i was really struggling
and i didn't know it i didn't know it
until the pandemic hit so thank god for
the pandemic a lot of people [__]
change their minds about a lot of things
after the [__] pandemic it's
just not me
so uh i don't feel like i'm a [__]
freak here for not wanting to do what i
was doing before sometimes in life you
just need to step back
and watch the game play and watch it and
you jump back in when the time is right
if the time is right and that's it i'm
happy with that that's what i've told
myself that's a [__] story i've uh
[__] served myself on a platter
and i'm gonna stick to it that's what
it's about you know what i'm saying
something happened this weekend a lot of
things happen that don't
like a lot of things happen in life that
affect you guys
like you'll hit me up on twitter what do
you think of this oh my god and i'll go
who gives a [__] you know like what what
how does it affect your [__] life you
know
and
it's a bad attitude to have because i
don't really respond
to a lot of things i respond to the
weirdest
things that happen in you know
in the media i don't really give a [__]
what's going on you know
things are gonna happen they're gonna
blow it up they're gonna try to blow
smoke up your ass what's [__] new you
know
but something happened thursday night
that really
didn't affect me it just made me think
one of the things i hate the most about
what i do
i don't know if it's my job
i don't know how to describe this one of
the things i [__] hate the most is
when people are wasting talent
i was
very guilty of this for [__] years
for years i was guilty of this and it
and it bothered me while i was doing it
it bothered the [__] out of me i knew i
was doing it and that's the definition
of insanity
doing the same thing over and over again
if uh
knowing that it's [__] wrong you know
that's that's the definition
every time i did a line of coke yeah i
was having a great time but at the same
time i'm like
this is [__] crazy
this is just this is what it is it's
insanity doing the same [__] thing
over and over again with the same
[__] results you know
so
sad thursday night i was doing something
i don't know what the [__] i was doing
what i usually do mercy had kickboxing
whatever we're
getting ready and i thought they were
doing the hall of fame
inductions for the ufc
great you know no biggie
i saw gsp with this trainer
uh farook whatever his name is for hob
[__] great trainer smart as [__]
i saw a bunch of other people there but
i saw jon jones he looked [__] yolk
he looked happy i was like [__]
look at john man he looks [__] great
he's he's going up to two [__] 70
that's that strength lifting he looks
stronger than a [__] bull not that he
wasn't a [__] elite athlete before
and i'm like [__] man i'm happy for him
he got inducted into the hall of fame
and
blah blah blah you know
this is great and i didn't think
anything else of it i was involved with
my own [__] you know i'm trying to write
a [__] book i'm trying to outline a
chapter who the [__] knows what i was
doing
friday morning i wake up i'm you know
whatever i go to the gym
i practice the guitar right
i don't know whatever the [__] i do on
fridays you know i don't even know what
i did yesterday this [__] monday
and uh no yesterday i went to jimmy's
for football [__] great time
watch vegas against miami it was the
return of tony bondi one of the funniest
guys in america i know what i [__] do
every day i'm just [__] with you guys
i just gotta take a minute to think
about it you know what i'm saying i
gotta scratch my head and go what did i
have for [__] lunch yesterday
but uh
yeah when i woke up friday you know
whatever the [__] was going on then at
one point in the afternoon
i heard jon jones had been arrested
one of my friends called he goes you see
jon jones got arrested and i'm like no
he didn't he just won the hall of fame
maybe it's an old article or whatever
he's like nah that [__] got
arrested
and i'm like okay so i got home later on
whatever the [__] that night i think i
remembered and i went online
and he got arrested for domestic battery
something else an assault and i'm like
5 30 in the [__] morning i'm like
what the [__] happened
he was just at the vegas thing
thursday night so that means he must
have stayed out and some [__] must have
happened
i'm like this is [__] crazy at this
kid then i heard dana white say that
[__] you know
every time he comes to vegas he's got to
sweat it out the [__] kid's crazy and
[__] i'm like
listen guys i'm a big fan of jon jones
uh
professionally and as a human being
i've always looked at john as
you know like me i
when i was 28 25 i was kidnapping people
but in my 30s
[__] got better for me and i'm saying
like you know
a little bit you know in my 40s they got
way better but
i look at john i i see a young man i see
a talented young [__] man
um
but i also see a guy that's been
overwhelmed
you know when somebody gets overwhelmed
in life
you have problems you know thank god
thank god i never had
i had zero success in my 20s
like thank god i was never good at
anything i never received an accolade in
my [__] 20s all i was was a [__]
the only accolade i got
was my the judge sentencing me to
[__] four to six years that's the
only accolade i [__] got in my 20s
but thank god
because i wouldn't be able to handle it
you know people are going crazy about
mcgregor well what do you think happens
when you throw 150 million at a [__]
kid
they're kids
and the punches to the head don't
[__] help
and the smoke blowing up your ass don't
[__] help people telling you you're
the greatest don't [__] help
it all works on your psyche in a way
that you've never [__] seen it unless
you've been there
i saw it in hollywood for years i saw
these kids being given the other there's
a show called home economics on abc
and it's a new show and nobody's going
to watch the [__] thing
uh it's no danger watching it home
economics i don't even recognize anybody
in the show i don't know who the [__] at
abc puts these shows on you know home
economics again
[__] miss pack got the second season
order bt the numbers were [__]
tremendous but abc's putting on home
economics you know about a family who
who strives together and gets [__] up
by wealth it's
just who gives a [__] well my point is
that one of the guys on the show
is the kid i did happy hour with
like in
19 i don't [__] know 2 000
4 or 3 i booked this [__] pilot
called happy hour it was one of my many
[__] pilot bookings all of them
horrific pilots right
except for bronze bronx county but we'll
get to that some other time
[__] uh
you know all of them were horrific
[__] pilots
this happy hour was a big pilot at fox
fox was
putting a lot around this [__] happy
hour thing
so
they had the original cast you know and
they just needed a couple extra
bolts put into the [__] cast what
they needed was an injection of funny
in the show
and i knew one of the guys on the show
and he's like dog
we need an injection i'm [__] funny
here like i said to you [__]
whenever you're putting the show
together yeah you call the improv and
the laugh factory and they'll give you
all the witty comics but when you want a
funny [__] to come into your
[__] set you call the comedy store
why because we're the [__] marines of
comedy we'll go down there and start
blowing [__] up and [__] gadgets and
you know what's that [__] movie with
the helicopter snake pit 40 [__] you
know forget yeah air force 90 whatever
the [__] it is i don't [__] know we
that's what we do we come in and blow
the [__] joint up
so the dude calls me
i go down there i [__] uh you know i
audition blah blah blah blah blah blah
and uh
i get the [__] rope
now i get there
and guys when i walk on a [__] set
i'm a [__] professional what does
that mean i'm not like any other comic i
don't try to steal the thunder
i go i go in my [__] corner i take my
sides i learn my sides and i shut my
[__] mouth i don't speak unless i'm
spoken even back then even back then
even more
because i didn't have the confidence i
had towards the end this is early on
when i didn't really know what was going
on i was still doing coke and i wasn't
telling people to go [__] themselves yet
if you would go off on me i'd [__]
take the to hear beating from me and go
in my [__] corner because i didn't
want my little secret to get out so
i get to this [__] table read that
you know they're okay
but i'm [__] funny guys you know on
this whatever the guy wrote for me was
great and i'm really blowing up this
[__] scene
and i could tell that these other
[__] [__] mix
none of them [__] like what i'm doing
you know they were all young you know
they were all very young one guy came
from the commercial uh
life he had booked a lot of commercials
the other chick was an improv check from
boston you know like uh what do they
call those people that you know not not
the groundlings but the other one
whoever the [__] that they're just as
bad too
it doesn't really matter and the other
guy was the kid from happy hour john
who's a great guy you know i'm not
saying anything about
uh home economics john is his name not a
bad guy he was always a very good
guy and he knew who the [__] i was and
he knew what i could do i don't know why
he came to me he's like that shit's
[__] hilarious but as the days went
on there her rehearsals i could tell
that they didn't [__] like me they
were turning on me because
they they weren't funny
no between the four of them put together
they couldn't say a [__] funny thing
they'd never settle for anything in
their life
i could see it they didn't start liking
me
and i shot the pilot we were done
hahahas and he he's you were amazing all
that [__] you know
and come pick up the show got picked up
i never heard [__] not a word from
these [__]
not even a [__] friendly [__] you
that i hear from these [__] no
big deal
austin they start shooting and
i called my friend i go hey dog not for
nothing
i went in there and did my job got the
show picked up put some laughs in there
help the other guy with some of their
lines
what nobody's calling me to [__] back
and he's like
uh let me get back to you you know so he
called me back like three days later
he's like listen
can i talk to you about something it was
the first show that the people from the
70s show
the people who created the 70s show this
was their first show
after the 70s show
so
you know whatever they they're the ones
that hired me they liked me so i knew
they liked me they were talking to me
during the thing and we're like we'll
see you in september if the show gets
picked up
but all of a sudden now i'm not hearing
from them so i called the [__] kid
one day and i go what's going on
and he calls me he goes let me call you
back when i got a minute and he goes
listen i don't know how to say this to
you he goes joey i love you i'm the one
that gave you the job
but he goes uh
some of the cast members
don't like you
you know he goes they just don't like
you
one guy said that you smell like reefer
one guy said this one guy said that he
goes it's all [__] i could tell
that you kind of intimidate him you know
your experience you know what the [__]
you're doing you know
and uh
i'll never forget that like
they
never used me you know my feelings were
a little hurt obviously i was green
i didn't know what was going on
but
like i took it like a man i go [__] it
on to the next one no big deal and i had
a gig at that place at rogan one night
that improv place
where a lot of them had come from
and when i went to eat dinner there was
a sushi place
next to them when i was eating dinner i
saw a couple of the people
from the pilot and they were like
[__] pale they wouldn't say [__] to
me you know and you know me i gotta walk
over
i gotta walk over and say hello and i
just wanna let them know that i knew
what they did
i wasn't angry
and that good luck to them and when i
walked over they were like [__]
pickles and i was like hey it's okay
you know i'm here to do comedy blah blah
blah you know good luck to you guys
the [__] girl told me she bought a
house
you know and the [__] kid told me he
bought a house not the kid from home
economics the kid that came from the
commercial world they were like bragging
they bought these houses with the pilot
and that you know they were they were on
episode three when i saw them
well guess what
i left that i didn't think anything bad
of them
when i left there maybe a week later the
show got cancelled
so i always thought about those two
idiots that bought houses
and what they were gonna do now she was
like an improv teacher what's that pay a
dollar a [__] day you make more
[__] money you know
so
they were young
that's the point of their story
they were [__] young
and
they just didn't know they they got
caught up in the whim the show got
cancelled they had to move on i never
saw them again i saw the commercial kid
and a couple commercial auditions he
wouldn't even make eye contact
and then one day i went to the ymca
and i saw the guy john
from home economics the abc show and i
remember he came over and he goes hey
man
like a man that's why i love john like a
man he came over and he said hey man i
didn't like what they did to you
i wasn't a part of that he always spoke
to me when i was on the set so i knew he
wasn't lying to me
and i appreciated it but that's what
happens
when you're young we've seen it
a thousand [__] times
you can't handle what's coming at you
let me tell you something
if you would have gave me like a [__]
anything
anything any amount of money when i was
snorting 35 37 i wouldn't show up to the
set the next day i was one of those guys
dawg i just wouldn't show i didn't give
a [__]
you know thank god i did baseball and i
kept up with that and all you know i
never really but the word was getting
out i made a few mistakes on the longest
yard you know i was young
i was a junkie never mind i was young i
was long and the [__] dude i was an
old man already in my 40s but
when you're young you just don't know
how to [__] handle this and that's
what they've done
with jon jones and
the reason why i was kind of blown away
was because
i thought he had this
under control we haven't heard nothing
from him in a couple years you know
maybe a year and a half
two years you know i think he got into
trouble in albuquerque at a [__]
strip club but really quick before we
move on i got to talk to you about some
people that have really helped me out
there's two things that have really
helped me the last three months
you guys know i was struggling the last
three or four months like i said last
week if you listen to the podcast
uh the earlier episodes up to maybe
december or january i was really
struggling to find words i was
struggling to hold thoughts i was
struggling to keep my thoughts together
one thing that really has always helped
me is generally
the other thing that helped me because
it's a you got to attack this type of
[__] it's like a three-prong operation
you know it's like a three-prong you got
to cover this [__] and i remember from
my halfway house days that you got to
cover all this [__] from three different
prongs so you know i started journaling
i started taking alpha brain and i did
something that i never [__] thought i
would do
i started talking to a therapist at
better health
okay the joint is brought to you by
better help today what's standing in
your way are you achieving your goals
you could figure it out with better help
i figured it out better help is therapy
for the 21st century this is not a
crisis hotline this is not self-help
better help is professional therapy and
it's all done online it's all remote no
waiting room no couches it's a flexible
schedule you get a great match they'll
put you together with a licensed
therapist who's right for you
the most important part of therapy
is you need to speak to someone you feel
like you could talk to somebody who gets
you i have dear friends and i talk to
them all the time but it wasn't cutting
at this time this time i needed a little
bit more help something was bothering me
and i needed to identify
what was bothering me the [__]
triggers and what was creating this
[__] anxiety in my life
and better help came through for me my
therapist's name is dana if you're
struggling
this might be something that will work
for you it's inexpensive it doesn't cost
you an arm and a leg right now if
because of the pandemic
this [__] pandemic is making
everybody's mental health go upside down
so you cannot find a good therapist
you're gonna have to go online with
better help it's cheap it's inexpensive
you can make your own schedule i see her
every two weeks if i need to see it you
could message them they get right back
to you after their session i mean this
is a great option for you and you do it
right from the privacy of your own home
nobody knows you got to do it but when i
do it i'll do it in the morning i come
back here i turn the light on i put my
little computer on you could do it over
the computer you could do it over zoom
you could do it over the [__] phone
it works and it helps do me a favor it's
affordable you don't have to be a fancy
ass new yorker and they have financial
aid available
that you can't beat better help
is 100 remote and available worldwide
so if you're in spain you could do it if
you're in germany you could do it
trust me it helps to have somebody from
outside your world to talk to it's easy
to schedule it's affordable and it'll
take a big load off your mind
now for the listeners from the church
the joint family this is what we're
doing better help has a great offer to
get you started visit betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
diaz and what i'm going to do is i'm
going to get your 10 off on your first
month
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
diaz
get better help and start living a
happier life identify what the hell is
bothering you and take care of it like i
did i didn't know what was eating away
at me i had like three or four things
that were eating away at me and ever
since i got together with better help i
feel better i'm acting better i'm making
better choices
and it's working so i'm here to tell you
go to betterhelp.com preston joey and
i'm going to save you 10 off your first
month just to get the ball started you
know therapy ain't for any everybody
you know
i don't do it for long it's like a half
hour on that i don't need to sit there
on a couch there's no watches in front
of your eyeballs there's none of that
[__]
i'm still writing my goals i'm still
doing all that [__] and the difference
about jiu jitsu for me this time than
last time
is i'm i got a notebook last time i was
on this thing bjj whatever way you write
down what you learned
but that's not what i was doing wrong
you know what i wasn't doing what i was
doing wrong when i went to jiu jitsu
last time
i didn't have a jiu jitsu goal
so this time i made a goal i'm not going
to tell you because i'm embarrassed i'll
take in a few weeks when i get up to it
but i'm embarrassed so i'll tell you
what i made a goal for my 60th birthday
so that puts me away from a year and a
half so
that's how you do it back to jon jones
it breaks my heart because nothing
breaks my heart more
than wasted talent i was wasted talent
not that i knew i was gonna be a [__]
comic or be in the movies or voiceovers
and [__]
but i knew as a human being i wasn't
doing myself any favors
by continuing to live the life that i
was living i'm not good at a lot of
things
i'm not [__] good at a lot of things
i know that for a fact
i struggle with the guitar i struggle
with jiu jitsu i'm good at maybe two
things [__] bullshitting and lifting
weights that that that's it i don't know
anything else
it's
it's scary i don't have any [__]
skills you know it's [__] scary but
one skill i do have that i could help
anybody with
that i know this is life coaching
you know
and i did it all myself i didn't [__]
go talk to anybody i didn't know what i
was doing
you know like i told you guys 10 years
ago
it wouldn't even be a thought for me to
talk to somebody i don't like talking to
people about my [__] problems i
rather tell you my [__] problems than
one person one-on-one brow beating you
right now when i tell you my [__] you
can't judge me you're just sitting at
home going holy [__] joey i didn't
[__] know about that it's not you're
gonna go whoa i didn't know you [__]
kidnapped somebody you know none of that
[__] so that's why it's easy for me
to talk to you guys but i did it
listen man let's let's talk about
something that's a [__] reality
you know i don't like to [__] pat
myself in the back i haven't had police
contact
since 1997.
i got pulled over maybe twice one for
uh i was looking at my phone the cop
pulled me over and another time i was
speeding on the way home coming home
from the five
i think two years ago i was going to
jujitsu and a cop seen me look at my
screen he pulled me over but as far as
like
anything like that i have not had police
contact since 1997 when i got out of
prison in 80 [__] nine
i was the captain of [__] police
contact if you guys remember me telling
your story february 3rd 1990 when my
daughter jacqueline was born
that morning i had just gotten out of
the halfway house
and i had [__] i got into a fist
fight and the cops came and they let me
go i got 20 [__] stories like that
that happened to me after i got out of
prison i didn't learn my lesson when i
got out of prison i did
but i didn't
the reason why things were always
[__] going back [__] crazy around me
was
you ready for this and i'll tell you
honest to god
cocaine when you're doing cocaine
even if you're staying at home
shit's gonna happen in your life that
you're not gonna explain because it's
bad [__] luck it's just bad
[__] look
how do i know because i [__] lived it
i know what it is to have be knee-deep
in [__] cocaine you're never safe
you're never home
you could pick up a girl one night at a
bar from home to your house do a couple
lines next thing you know your
paranoia's got the best of you think
your girl took a [__] line of coke
like shotgun doug when i told you guys
that story last year and next thing you
know the cops are coming to your house
because you you're yelling at the
[__] girl now you got domestic
[__] violence you got [__]
possession of cocaine god knows what
else you have in the [__] house but
trust me i'm not listen
if jon jones is watching this or
whatever i'm not saying you're doing
coke
but there's something that has to be
going on there's two things okay
there's two things you could do
and this is how i don't want you guys to
think that
i'm saying that i'm smarter when you
guys and anything
last night my my cousin called me a
saturday night
when i was watching the fights my cousin
called me roloff fito
i didn't pick up because i had a friend
of mine here and i didn't want to be
rude but
he was my cousin from florida uh his
father
my mother was his sister's godmother
but we were always like cousins and [__]
like that you know how it is
he called the other we talked for a
little while
whatever
i forgot what the [__] i was going to
tell you [__]
holy [__] i gotta do something about my
life no
uh
what's that
yeah i got what is that [__] that
[__] alpha brain that [__] brought me
back like roller fito yeah he called i
don't know what the [__] i was doing i
was watching
the ufc fight whatever the [__] and
i don't know well anyway what i was
talking about was that
there's two oh
when i was a kid
i went to miami one time and rodolfo his
father my cousin's father my uncle
rofito's father
was on probation
for a weapons charge or something but
the probation they had put them on
was sundown
sun up to sundown
that's what the probation program was
called
so you're allowed out
sun up
and you have to be down
by sundown you have to be in the house
by sundown
i didn't think it would make a
difference
okay
but it does
you know chris rock has a great [__]
line from one of his earliest specials
uh
nothing good is gonna happen if you go
to the atm at two in the morning
nothing good
comes from that when you go to the atm
at two in the morning it's definitely
for something bad okay
when you're out at night and listen
you're hearing it from me i i
experimented
for years on how to change my life and
you've heard me tell these [__]
stories and you know where i'm going
with this
you got to remember i was a [__]
hellion
till i was until 1997.
i always had police contact you know i
got to jail in 89
and i had a bunch of contact in boulder
and then on the road
i would have police contact remember i
got in trouble in idaho
i got into a fistfight and [__] uh
whatever springs and
there was always drama with me guys
always
i was getting pulled over i was [__]
always having police contact
misunderstandings when i came to jersey
in 93
i had police contact i had [__] five
altercations
that my life was never at [__] peace
so for years that's what my search was a
[__] piece yeah now i got it down but
it's 58 i'm an old man how many 58 year
olds gonna be out snorting [__] coke
jumping up and down going to strip clubs
don't answer that i'm sure there's a lot
of them i don't have that luxury here
i'm saying i don't have that luxury to
be snorting coke and [__] being at a
strip club my head would blow up i think
but
far be it from that i really would i
think my head would blow up you know
there's a strip club on the route 9 that
is always packed
the club 35 or club 35 i don't know what
it is
it's always packed the other night when
i was coming from the premiere i hadn't
been on the turnpike in months so the
other night when i was coming from the
premiere i actually looked to see what
was going on on a wednesday night
packed
people [__] everywhere and that
[__] you can see the cars parked
on top of one another you know i don't
have that [__] luxury right now and i
don't want that luxury i did all that
craziness
but i'll tell you what
a good birthday yeah they had a great
[__] buffet all i know is that
i
had all these problems
but before i went to la
i'd have a long talk with myself and i'm
like
you know i've been in seattle for 18
months i got arrested six times
before that i was in boulder and i can't
tell you how much police [__] contact
i had
before that you know i was in jersey and
i can't tell you how much police contact
i had
how am i gonna [__] stop this police
contact
and this is what i'm trying to say to
jon jones
that this is the shame of this this is
what bothers me
is wasted talent
it's when you're
at your best
and you're not taking advantage of it
you know and listen i know how it is
i know what it's like to get a [__]
paycheck from a comedy show and
[__] want to get your dick sucked and
you know i've been there i understand
i got to la in 97
i did not stop doing drugs 2007. again
there was no police contact
but i changed my life in a way
i cut it back i scaled it back
you know what the difference was
between my life in l.a
and my life before la
you ready
going out at night
you're like but joey you're a comic
you went out at night listen to what i'm
saying to you
i went out when i started to go out to
do comedy
and cut out the social [__] at the bars
my life changed completely
where does jon jones always get in
trouble
when he goes up
when he goes out now
i'm not telling you
not to go out
i never said that
you see me i [__] go out i'm never
saying you're not to go out at night i
moved to l.a in 1997.
i stayed there till 2020
and i never had police contact except
for
driving that day i mean never did a cop
come and talk to me
for drugs [__] this
that i got a ticket for parking and a
handicapped spot two days after 9 11
whatever the [__]
yeah that that's it
yeah but my life was always
a rest sheets 36 arrests
before i move to [__] boulder and you
know these are realities of life guys so
if anybody knows what the [__] they're
talking about i know what the [__] i'm
talking about when it gets to that if
your life is always with this [__]
turmoil
think about it you have to
[__] journal it down to the [__]
mind you fact
that you're going out at night think
about it it's you're going out and it's
your [__] drinking
i made a conscious decision in 1997 that
people hated me for people hated me for
that [__] decision of not going out
my business was stand up that's it
and i had rules on my stand-up i had a
ton of [__] rules
i was not allowed to do cocaine until i
got off the stage
that was a personal [__] rule i was
not allowed to do cocaine at the club
where i was [__] uh
doing comedy at take the coke out of the
business don't have the coke there at
all even at the comedy store i would
have a drink maybe two drinks do a line
i did not want anybody to see me [__]
up all my problems were always after
[__] 10 o'clock
my life changed and my problems ended at
10 o'clock why are you getting arrested
at five [__] 30 in the morning you're
a [__] champion
why the [__] are you out at 5 30 in the
[__] morning i have not been out of
this house at 5 30 in the [__]
morning
well
about three months ago i went to l.a i
had to [__] leave the house at five
[__]
15 or something but besides that it's
been [__] years
i want jon jones to get his life
together i want you guys
to get your life together i should not
be pointing out jon jones half of us are
doing this this is what's happened after
the pandemic
and then you wonder why your [__]
life is a sham listen if anybody's life
was a sham it was mine but if anybody
turned their life around it was me and i
haven't thought about this in a long
[__] time
between you guys and [__] derek and
[__]
catherine narducci you opened up my mind
you guys made me think
to what i had done what the purpose of
this mission was
it wasn't to be a [__] stand-up
comedy you know what man listen
yeah i went to a premiere last week does
that make me a better person than you no
no i worked hard at something
and i finally made my [__] uh
finally my ship came in that's what you
call it you're ship coming in
no big [__] deal it happens but you
gotta [__] commit to it you gotta
commit to something you gotta believe in
something
why not believe in me oh [__] anyway
that's a little bit of the point of
sisters there what i'm trying to say to
you [__] if you want your life
to change
you got to take control you got to take
the bull by the [__] orange listen i
did something that a lot of people did
not think i could ever do i accomplished
becoming a man you know what that
accomplishment was for me
that's huge i'm when i went to that
premier league on that of the many
saints in newark
that didn't make me better than you that
didn't make me a man
i became a man on my own that movie was
part of my [__] journey
to be a man i've arrived i'm home listen
it took me 58 years i'm a [__] [__]
i'm no better than you [__]
took me 58 [__] years
but i did it and that's all that [__]
has ever mattered to me
at all
so this podcast is not intended at jon
jones
i was just in shock
that after all this time he's still
[__] getting arrested you're a
[__] champion
act like that
even me who's a [__] [__] you know
my grandparents were second cousins and
they got married so i got [__] blood
of me but even me it was a [__]
[__] could tell you one thing
the opportunity i had
to be allowed to be at the store and to
be in la
i never thought i was as talented at
three-quarters of the people in l.a i
thought i was forcing myself on the
scene okay
things turned out that i was talented
and i made [__] some moves and i got
a little bit of success and i got a
couple movies and a couple tv shows and
i shot a few specials but that doesn't
make me a better [__]
person than you
it contributes to my manhood
that's what i did i [__] accomplished
something i moved the [__] on and now
i'm i am moving on i did what i had to
do and that's it
and
listen man you might be having some
problems right now whatever i'm not
telling you to [__] stop doing drugs
that's not my [__] job you know i'm
not telling you to stop going out and
partying
i'm just telling you to look at your
life
and see the different [__] things you
could do
just to make it a little [__] better
you hear my stomach growling that's
[__] hunger yeah
no that's my [__] stomach ground i
only had my two egg yolks my piece of
wheat bread and my two piece of bacon
for breakfast you know me dog i'm
sticking to my weight watchers [__] yeah
i eat my sausage sandwich from time to
time i had a half a lobster tail last
night one of the good ones with the
[__] cream in it oh my god ferraris
had a stand over there it is so great to
be back in [__] jersey guys
i get to go to my little feast every
week
even my wife said something to me last
night she goes
this place seems to have something
different in every little community
every week
for kids this is what this is all about
and i'm happy we [__] made it like i
said this podcast was not intended to
bash jon jones at all i love john
this was to open up our eyes and if
you're going through the same things
just look at your life and see what
needs to be taken out
with me it was not going out at night
and like i told you guys
till this day people are still pissed
off at me i will not go to a bar
you guys do know that i don't go to
[__] bars to stand there i don't
drink
yeah i could go get high and talk to you
while i drink a soda it's not what i
want to do i've been in the bar since i
was [__] four years old i don't go to
bars no more i don't want to be in a bar
whatsoever when i stop going to bars
like when i do [__] comedy anybody
who goes on the road with me anybody
will [__] tell you
after the road
back to the room and that's the way it
was
since 2009 ask anybody and even before
that i had a hard time going out i would
go out for a little while to get a
cocaine package to wait for the dealer
to maybe pick up a chick but once all
that [__] came together
i was headed the [__] home that was the
way it worked for me and it worked
until this day it still [__] works
for me i go to people's houses i go to
[__] parties you know i go to
restaurants to eat dinner
i don't want to go to a bar and jump up
and down
whenever i see it on facebook or twitter
i feel bad for the people i go who the
[__] wants to be sitting inside a
[__] ball
but anyway whatever [__] works for
you
whatever makes your life [__] smooth
that's it that's the transition it works
for me and
i made it work for me and i hope it
works for [__] you
the premiere was great the movie was
great i'm looking forward to it on
[__] friday i hope you guys are
looking forward to it i've been going
back and forth
with the movie theater guy people are
[__] greedy guys
people want to make that money from uh
the pandemic so
we're still trying to put it together
for patreon to get a little screening
next week i'm doing a screening uh
tonight
i'm supposed to go to uh
i'm supposed to go to one of the i think
it's uh
eatontown on thursday on wednesday night
and tonight it's
the monmouth whatever i'll find out and
i'll put it on twitter for you guys and
instagram
and that's it and that's that we [__]
did it
it's the last week of [__]
september
and uh
that's it man
time is moving right along and as you
can tell
time doesn't wait for [__] nobody
take whatever you can from this podcast
i love you guys
thank you for supporting the joint thank
you for having my back
now for a word for my [__]
sponsor jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you for all the support and
love you give me every week
you're hooking us up me and michael the
joint is brought to you by draftkings
listen
three weeks of football are in the
[__] books it's time to review the
tape how did you do
did you want any money did you [__]
have fun no you didn't you know why
because you weren't at draftking sports
book the official sports betting partner
of the nfl
i am loving it you understand me
yesterday i made it
maybe two bets i had the la rams you
know mean guys i love all that [__]
and then i bet [__] whatever the
other night and i took a beating but it
don't matter because draftkings take
scare you they got an offer now that's
bananas they're giving all new customers
150 dollars instantly
just bet a dollar any football game nfl
or pro you [__] heard me you sack of
[__] head to draft king sports book app
today
download the draftking sports but got
better dollar and get 150
in free bets instantly now if the sports
book is not available in your states
draftkings has huge cash prizes for
grabs all season long on the fantasy the
daily fantasy contest they're giving
away millions of dollars
all you need is a [__] dollar you
understand me however you play
draftkings gonna give all new customers
a free shot at a million dollars plus
they're safe secure and reliable
you can't put a bed and you still got
the casino you know what i'm saying
blackjack a little poke a little
roulette you don't want to do that you
can still bet mma mma ain't your thing
you got football football ain't your
thing you got the baseball playoffs
download the draftking sportsbook app
today
use promo code joey and get a hundred
and fifty dollars in free bets when you
place a dollar bet on any football game
that's promo code joey j-o-e-y
this week at draftking sportsbook app
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl and the ufc new jersey indiana
pennsylvania colorado west virginia
tennessee new customers only minimum
five dollar deposit and a dollar wager
required that's six dollars to get your
[__] party started one per customer
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now you got a
gaming problem i understand call 1-800
gambler when indiana called 109 with it
but if you're taking care of everything
and you're ready to have some fun and
win some money download the draftking
sportsbook app it's time to win some
money
and the draftkings fantasy app you're
gonna have a great [__] time and you
won't be sorry
draftkings the [__] leader use code
joey
the joint is also brought to you by
better help
listen what's standing in your way are
you reaching your goals you know you
better help is professional therapy all
online it's all remote no waiting room
you got a flexible schedule you want to
do phone calls video calls they're all
at your convenience
you get a good match they'll put you
with a licensed therapist who's right
for you they put me with dana
and she's pushed me from a to z that's
the most important part of your therapy
you need someone you can talk to you
feel
like that you're comfortable who gets
you
dana got me and that's why i'm here
telling you about better help it's fast
when you sign up you can start talking
to your therapist in less than 48 hours
no waiting around it's affordable you
don't have to be a fancy ass to pay for
this and financial aid is available and
you can send messages to your therapist
anytime and they'll get back to you in
between sessions
don't like your person if you want to
switch per therapist you can do it
anytime for free they make it nice and
easy listen you guys know me a long time
better help is tremendous how do i know
because it's helped me i sound better
i'm sleeping better i'm acting better
and i'm making better decisions you
don't have to live in a big city to get
quality therapy anymore it's right here
in front of you online in the privacy of
your own home it's easy to schedule it's
affordable and it'll take a big load off
your shoulders like it did for me over a
million people have taken charge of
their mental health
join them
better help has a great offer to get you
started visit betterhelp.com
diaz right now
and i'm going to get you 10 off your
first month that's a deal in excel
because it's already cheaper than
expensive it's easy to schedule and you
could talk to somebody within 48 hours
that's better help
spell it out b-e-t-t-e-r
help h-e-l-p
slash diaz to 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
diaz
better help start living a better life
today
with better help okay the joint is also
brought to you by
bowl and branch listen
you got to have nice sheets it's not
about your mattress the sheets if they
hug you right and they're soft that can
make the night
bowling brand sheets i have just extra
soft plus they're 100 organic and
sustainably produced
listen these sheets are tremendous uh
i like the signature hem sheets they're
the best sellers for a reason they get
softer with every wash okay these sheets
are buttery soft and especially
lightweight they don't stick to you they
come in a variety of colors and every
size
from twin to california king and here's
something else to help you sleep bowling
brand sheets are made by craftsmen who
earn a fair living wage all the bone and
branch products are made using safe and
fair conditions plus
they got a worry-free
guaranteed for 30 nights
to experience the best sheets you've
ever felt choose bowling branch you can
try them worry free for 30 nights with
free shipping and returns so try them
you got nothing to lose
the joint listeners get up 15 off
your first set of sheets with promo code
joey
at
bowlingbranch.com
that's promo code joey at
bowlingbranch.com i love you guys i want
to thank bowling branch i want to thank
draftkings the leader and i want to
thank better help who's going to help
you get back
to tip mop top magoo i love you guys
have a great week thank you for
listening
and i'll see you guys wednesday
the 29th to ready to [__] rock have a
great [__] day have a great week
uncle joey loves you paul sniffers stay
black
so
you